i just wanted to mention this this is
from pink news of course one of my
favorite media outlets
it says u.s president joe biden honored
the dozens of trans people lost to a
horrifying wave of violence on
transgender day of remembrance
on saturday the world grew silent as
countless memorialized and celebrated
the lives of victims of anti-trans
violence among them was biden who in a
white house news release paid tribute to
those we lost in the deadliest year on
record for transgender americans
the
white house later hosted a vigil in
recognition of trans non-binary and
gender non-conforming people lost to
violence
with second gentleman doug imhoff
leading the ceremony
but seemingly capturing the extent of
the climate of fear felt by trans
americans biden's address was out of
date mere moments after it was published
it says uh this is biden he said quote
this year at least 46 transgender
individuals in this country were killed
in horrifying acts of violence
and then it goes on to say that actually
the death toll now is 48.
okay
so it's the deadliest year on record for
trans people
so deadly that the president united
states needs to hold a vigil for them
how many trans people have been murdered
48
the entire year up to now in the whole
country
now all murders are very sad
but but
what what do we expect exactly do we
expect the the trans murder rate to be
zero
all people
no matter what group you belong to no
matter what your gender identity is you
are susceptible to potentially being
murdered unfortunately because you're a
mortal human being
and so you take any random group we
could take plumbers let's just take
plumbers or you know how many plumbers
have been murdered this year
probably not zero
does that automatically mean that
there's some sort of anti-plumber hate
crime epidemic
no what we find is that actually
the trans murder rate is very very low
it is significantly lower it's like a
third
of the murder rate of the general
population
okay so i say that again if you're a
trans person statistically you are
much less likely to be murdered than if
you are a non-trans person
and then if you look at the at the
individual cases because you'll notice
something
when we're told about the trans uh you
know hate crime epidemic supposedly
um
they're always very vague about it
they say 48 trans people have been
murdered and those are all of the
murders and they sort of vaguely say oh
hate and discrimination
but then if you ask well
you know can you give me some examples
of like are you saying that there are
people out there hunting trans people
and murdering them for being trans
can you give me some examples of that is
that all 48 of them
that's when they go silent because in
reality when you actually look at the
individual cases as i have done
and others have done
so amari has an article about it uh
today i think in the new york post
uh the federalist has has done some
research into this when you look at the
individual cases you discover
that
in almost every case when a trans person
is murdered it's because it's
drug-related it's gang-related it's
prostitution related
um or it's related or it's related to
domestic violence
in other words it's it's the same reason
why most people are murdered
same kind of risk categories apply to
trans people as applies to the general
population
anti-trans hatred or bigotry has nothing
to do with almost any of it
and yet they still talk about the trans
hate crime epidemic which is a total
fabrication it's a fantasy it doesn't
exist for the record
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated